en temps de guerre il est des hommes et
des femmes qui ne sont pas soldats mais
qui arpentent la ligne de front pour
dédier leur vie à celle des autres
Mireille l'eau et son groupe de
volontaires sont de ceux-là Milana
l'assurance et l'insouciance de ces 19
ans
malgré tout ces bombardements le dernier
c'était là et là j'ai un peu nettoyé les
graves à moi-même c'était quand même un
peu effrayant
une salve de roquette a atterri juste
devant l'abri souterrain qu'ils
arrangent depuis une semaine à Oulai
Pollet ville fantomatique ravagée 2000
personnes ils sont quand même restés
pour tout le monde c'est la routine mais
pour moi c'est un miracle ici à il y a
Paul c'est le seul point d'eau courante
eau potable nourriture électricité grâce
au groupe électrogène miraïlo appelle
cela un point d'invincibilité un terme
apparu en Ukraine pour signifier que
ceux qui persistent à demeurer dans ses
localités en ruine peuvent y survivre
malgré tout
vous voulez prendre une douche avant
l'invasion russe Mireille l'eau vivait à
Mario Paul patron d'une entreprise
informatique de 80 personnes et
propriétaire d'une boîte de nuit au
premier jour de l'offensive il est parti
avec ses quatre enfants avant d'y
retourner
je suis revenu le 7 mars à Mario Paul
pour prendre soin des employés de ma
boîte de nuit et quand je suis arrivé
dans le sous-sol il y avait des gens qui
en avaient fait un abri je me suis
occupé d'eux il y avait 200 personnes
j'ai commencé à les évacuer c'est comme
ça que j'ai commencé à être volontaire
j'ai fait cette évacuation et la
dernière c'était depuis l'usine
d'avostale
[Musique]
o a commencé seulement ils sont 15 à le
suivre dans la période mission qu'il
s'est fixé établir des refuges sécurisés
dans ces villes qui tentent de résister
au bombardement russe
Mario Paul lavedivka origine france 24
avait rencontré Mireille l'eau en
décembre dernier à baroute à
inlassablement protégé autrui et tenter
d'évacuer les plus fragiles
si vous voulez évacuer je peux vous
proposer une maison c'est vraiment très
bien idéal pour les enfants
de profondeur et un lieu
de se battre certains sont en Europe et
se battent en envoyant de l'argent
d'autres sont actifs juste sur les
réseaux sociaux et font des likes chacun
à son propre front et aide comme il peut
beaucoup de jeunes qui nous rejoignent
ils veulent faire partie de quelque
chose nous on crée une petite partie de
l'histoire et peut-être de la victoire
vont reprendre la route pour une autre
cité dévastée un autre refuge à
installer et une fois inébranlé en la
solidarité au début de l'invasion russe
l'Ukraine a montré le visage d'une
nation héroïque et unie 15 mois après si
la lassitude peut se faire sentir dans
les régions éloignées les combats ces
volontaires perpétuent l'esprit de
résistance un esprit entretenu par
l'État qui distribue médaillée au nord
autant aux militaires cociville ces
volontaires eux n'ont reçu qu'un bout de
papier avec marqué dessus merci